mais d'abord une crise alimentaire
chasse l'autre au niger mauvaises
récoltes sécheresse criquets géant on
affame et plus de trois millions et demi
de personnes en 2005
combien en 2006 les ong affirment qu'une
deuxième crise aussi grave et imminente
même s'il n'ya mais soucieuse de
préserver les apparences conteste ses
prévisions vincent fichman comme un air
de déjà vu
toujours les mêmes femmes qui passions
des heures durant pour quelques kilos de
mil toujours les mêmes humanitaire qui
part au plus urgent quelques mois après
la crise de cet été
le niger a toujours faim la spirale de
la pauvreté est engagé depuis plusieurs
années une spirale dont le pays peine à
sortir malgré une récolte cette année
plutôt meilleure que d'habitude
la majorité des gens qui ont récolté un
accès sont des pays qui ont des dettes
qui doit voir rembourser après la
récolte un pouvant rester avec un peu
dans les renier signe que la crise est
profonde mais niamey la capitale ne
compte plus les victimes de la
malnutrition ambiante
les hôpitaux sont saturés à l'intérieur
toujours les mêmes scènes on estime ici
qu'un enfant sur cinq souffre de
malnutrition
ça c'est dans des villes comme niamey
qui procède avec en même temps la
capitale où les conditions de vie sont
supposés être meilleur qu'un mélodrame
les zones plus rurales
cela pourrait être ici à thann où la
situation est inquiétante comme ailleurs
mais les humanitaires ont une petite
idée pour sortir de la crise persuadé
que si l'on souffre de faim on souffre
aussi avant tout d'une pauvreté
endémique
alors on préfère distribuer de l'argent
plutôt que des céréales
ce projet vise à soutenir les ménages
des villages les plus affectés par la
crise alimentaire qui sévit au sahel en
fournissant à ses ménages
soutien financier qui leur permet de se
première mans de survivre et
deuxièmement de pouvoir assurer un
retour à la vie économique malgré
l'évidence de la détresse de sa
population
le gouvernement nigérien ni la crise
actuelle dernièrement les principaux
responsables s'en sont pris aux ong qui
n'aurait pour seul but que d'entacher
l'image du pays
quelques jours avant l'ouverture des
jeux de la francophonie à niamey
mais face à l'urgence le programme
alimentaire mondial n'en démord pas on
est bien à l'aube d'une gigantesque
crise alimentaire